what was freddy mercury like in bed
sounds like I don't know there was seven
other people there do pool remember of
my 27th birthday member saying to my mom
I don't want to live beyond 27 and my
mom was like why I was just like I just
for 27 was like kind of the end of the
road type thing my mom's like don't be
so stupid
27 like temazepam diazepam rohypnol they
were kind of like the pegging parts of
the cocaine so I would take cocaine I
take down it to suppress the cocaine I
would drink alcohol to level cocaine on
our table and then of course I
discovered three Basie and crack and
then I discovered crystal meth when I
finally went to I would sleep in the
recovery position because I was that
scared that I was gonna choke on my own
vomit every night music is the best and
biggest drug I've ever taken it has the
ability to transport you to anywhere in
the world and to be with people that
you're no longer with no longer with us
DJ Fat Tony in the building how are you
okay I'm good I've uh I've been yeah
Mike's you like to do vanilla the last
few weeks
I'm okay I'm good now you had the Rona
yeah I did yeah it kind of I kind of was
like I went for a whole week of pink you
know this is a right I can do this it
was kind of a mild flu bad chest but I
was wise enough to ask my well my doctor
decided he wanted to put me on steroids
to my chest cuz I have a bad chest
anyway so thankfully I took steroids on
the then it went away on the first day
yeah it's already good Friday night boom
temperature for 8:40 in the 40s for four
days and four nights the worst fever
went into my chest I was breathless it
was awful
yeah awful that's them goods now feeling
yeah I'm okay I'm just taking it easy to
go I mean I mean no rush to go anywhere
so it's not a problem but yeah thank God
I had it mild yeah yeah I guess so so my
first question is why why you called Fat
Tony when you're not fat that I don't
question I when I was a kid I was a fat
kid I got fat about the age of 14 to see
steam are kind of it was a coping
mechanism for what I was going through
so I kind of you know put on loads of
weight as its you know it's a barrier
between other people and me because I
kind of went through I love it though
sexual abuse at an earlier age so I kind
of just got fat as a protection so you
know it's one of those names that people
call kind of whispered behind your back
so I just kept it you know at sixteen
and it's interesting that two years of
being fat like ages ago
has branded you for the rest of your
life like yeah it's one of those things
people go you should change your name
and it's like why would I change my name
it's taking me around the world seven
times Jeremy nice inside made a career
out of that name I'm not going to change
it I think there was a a year and a half
in the 80s where I changed it to fat PHT
pH eighty okay yeah yeah yeah well I
don't hip hop for a week but yeah yeah
so um I first heard of you as some of
the people listening may have done
through this recent mixmag documentary
which has come out which is absolutely
phenomenal and I know I look but no
Wi-Fi there is we are currently in the
1800s and we're hoping to get the wheel
and fire and and operate in running
water soon but I mean in my defense they
referred to you this is Mixmag referred
to you as the most famous DJ you've
never heard of yeah the reason that was
that name came about was because said
who works for mixmag who he'd never
heard of me and he was from Cornwall so
you know and and I actually said to him
you know the reason you've not heard me
is because you you're from Cornwall you
don't you live in that [ __ ] live under a
stone in it in like a wooden shack you
know they probably haven't even got a
smartphone but yeah so that's why we
called it that because I don't really
like that I like the fact that people
haven't heard of me but you know my well
well I don't it didn't it doesn't
surprise me oh but I think you know to
touch on the way that industries work
especially nightlife right people bet
you from outside of the country might
look at the UK and just be like oh my
god it's just a spec it's a state
America right but especially with
partying because party culture is so big
in the UK it is there are you can go
from here to Middlesbrough where I'm
originally originally from yeah 45 miles
away and the industry is different the
music policies are different the cut the
type of events are different the
promoters you know there's no crossover
so it's a little microcosms they don't
surprise me yeah I mean you know come on
I don't expect anybody to know who I am
because you know the industry but the
thing about it was was because you know
my career shifted in so many different
areas throughout my career and right now
I've been in the last few years I've
been working with in fashion and all
that stuff so you know I kind of the
clubs I got to his level where the clubs
I would still do clubs they don't pay
the money that I could get from like in
command for doing that you know working
the Victoria Beckham or there's our show
any of those brands I work with so I you
know the whole idea of calling in the
most famous deed you've never horse cuz
I you know it was about tapping back
into that other market I've been apart
for a while yeah I mean it looks like
everyone that's listening will know the
local DJ that has a cup the resident
sees a week or maybe you know three four
residences a week at good events and it
looks great but it's a [ __ ] grind you
know like all of my buddies all my
buddies a resident DJ's work yeah three
or four nights a week think I've done
four in the morning you know grinding it
how it's hard work you know I've done
that for a lifetime
shego an amine and now I've got to this
level of odd contentment within my
career that I I've learnt that there's a
reputable thing about saying no and it's
a really powerful thing say no without
explanation I don't need I don't need to
explain why I'm saying no anymore and I
you know I turned down so many different
types of gigs because they're not where
I want to be right now I don't need to
be getting up at 5:00 in the morning to
go to work to go I mean don't get me
wrong that's really not me being a
noxious or take it for granted for what
I got but you know what I kind of you
know I'd rather to bigger than smaller
and some levels don't get me I do so so
different types of pies and events and
if they appeal to me I'll do them it
doesn't matter how much money is or
whatever but you know just got to that
stage where I don't really do
residency's anymore because I find that
when you become a resident you become a
piece of furniture and you get treated
like furniture you know the special the
the whole feeling of being special and
different is gone because you suddenly
there every week so people take you for
granted
there's no amazement about it you go
what I mean I could be like mom you just
go there and people get always there
again you Island him last week the bar
stuff you know you're just one of the
bar staff one of the glasses and for me
I don't want to be that anymore
I can't old you get that there's a cool
quote that I heard the other day about
saying no and it was the UM by saying no
you're only saying no to one thing am i
saying yes you are saying no to
everything else could you know why I
like which is like that I will say yes
to something that I don't want to do and
then I will get so much anxiety around
that that one thing that one thing will
keep me awake for three or four nights
or I will threaten and you know I will
get worked myself up to this place right
and then what I do is this day before I
pull a sickie or the day do I mean that
I just feel guilty after you furnishers
know you feel guilty you feel like
you've let yourself down you're letting
up people don't so there's something
really simple you know as an addict I'm
people please quite a lot throughout my
life I don't need to do that today today
the need to please one person that's my
selves if I'm happy everybody else is
happy and with the film you know with
that mix and I feel I really thought no
one was ever gonna watch it I got you
know it started off as an interview for
Mixmag and in the any of you I said oh
you know it's only taking you 35 years
to catch up and uh you know because
everyone they've had on they want the
majority of people they've got their
covers in that phase like is probably
stacking shelves right now she go on the
mainland whereas I can't continued
through and you know and then the boys
that mixed mag the interview came out I
got a really big really would great
reception and then they said oh we
really want to do an online thing
the next day so you find its to it so we
went up and did it and then two days
later they came back and they were like
oh you know what we want to we want to
think something bigger and I was like
fine you know I really like the guys
said and Louie they were great we're
really good fun to work with you know I
kind of just like their cheekiness no
because each day they do an interview
with me and then they could throw these
questions in at the end like on one day
said I would finish filming and then
simply like oh just one last question
and I was like what like what was
Freddie Mercury like in bed I was like I
don't know there was seven other people
there yeah Leoben I like that and that's
kind of just like the magic of what the
film came out like you know they they
brought it to my house to show me and I
was you know and I kind of like don't
know if I want to watch it because I you
know it's it's that the thing about it
is it's the truth and the truth hurts so
it's really hard sometimes to watch the
truth in black and white or an on screen
or read it and they showed me and it
made me cry it make each time I watch it
there's the parts in it that make me cry
because you know it really hits a nerve
and they showed me the film and they
were like I start to cry and they were
like dude you like it and I was like
yeah they were like is there anything
you want to change and I was like
probably 95% of it but base your film
and and you know what I respect it's
your film and you know what no I don't
want to change it I didn't want to
change anything you know apart from the
end I wanted them to pick me up a little
bit more he's doing now type thing yeah
because they kind of just put a few
things in oh so you might a little stick
it all in and their lives I action no
don't stick it all in
Joe I mean it doesn't need to all be
there Joe I mean it was kind of doing
those so we just left it as it was and
you know what it's had nearly three
million views it's insane it's a three
million phenomenal it's all good so
again if you haven't seen it it'll be
linked in the show notes below so once
we've finished no once you finish this
in the podcast go and check out is
absolutely may it's like that one of the
first long-form Facebook videos I've
seen with that a couple of million views
as well
unbelievable so ya blew me away the
bottom line is that your story resonates
with a lot of people it's interesting
and intriguing to a lot of people so I
want to give you an opportunity to kind
of delve into that and obviously show
people that haven't seen it what that
story is and then go further with with
it as well so where do we start with you
Korea where do you want to start with my
career any beginning yes you know I I I
used to work on the door of a nightclub
I mean I start going out really young
age start going out at the age of
fourteen tonight clubs got kicked out
school at 14 went to work in a place in
Kings Road which isn't charity which at
that time people walked up and down all
day long on Saturdays it was like it was
like social media so likes of Rome it
Boy George I met all most of my friends
would be walking up and down that road
because Punk had just come from that
from the drum Kings Road Chelsea so it
was the next big the next best thing the
next next biggest thing so put the
photographers will always be there it
was like I know at the place to go and
be photographed so I got a job working
there and then we start hanging out with
metal my friends um made new threat
honestly it made loads of our new circle
of friends and we started going out
clubbing and I would uh you know I would
I had a mouth I could get why I want it
I was the most obnoxious person you'll
ever meet you know I was always in
somebody's face so people just gave me
what I wanted and so I had this job on
this door of a club called the lice at
the Lyceum where lion kings playing it
presently in London it's a big theatre I
was working on that door and each week I
would moan about the music no reason no
reason at all just moaned about it and a
guy rusty who run the club said to me oh
if you could do better bring your own
tracks and that was it I kind of went
with four records to the next week and
uh within a month I was in New York
playing the whole day at this point I
was at that point I was 16 yeah 16 : 17
you and leach leads that was it or three
weeks down the line I'd started a new
night on a Tuesday with my friend
Stephen Leonard
club called wag club and we did a night
call total fashion week to him and I
kind of just spiraled from there you
know I kind of move in yeah as I say
we're getting a month month and a half I
had a residency in New York and gladium
and it's kind of just all went so yeah
that first period there from some fella
on the dorsum got lad on the door of a
venue to you know to being a guy with
four records to having a residency in
New York I mean that's the that's the
liftoff I think that's probably most
dramatic right like if you actually have
that kind of just it was in SATA you
know London was much different place
back then you know it had a nucleus of
love the weight which was the West End
which is Soho and that was it just so
that was the clubbing Mecca area so
everybody knew each other
London was a really exciting creative
time we didn't have social media so
everybody went out and going out was
where you met people and you know um so
everybody knew each other and and
they've won at that point London was
like the place to be everyone in New
York will each be in London and and
anyone and all the clubs in New York
wanted people from London so it just
kind of all fell into place and you know
yeah it literally happened so quickly
it's just like literally mad so you got
flown to New York by can't go to New
York every two weeks by who by uh by
Steve Rubell who and who used to own
studio 54 he went it they got rid of 54
and then they opened this new super Club
Cooke lady up there and you had Schrager
stray cat owned like area the supper
club down the road and all of those
clubs so I kind of got you move all that
lot it's kind of it really mad yeah yeah
that's insane what's it feel like it's a
16 year old flying to New York to play
records having a DJ for a Monday it was
kind of an actually was about I was
about 17 because I remember I went to
New York the for my birthday my 18th
from Concorde and then I got I'd stopped
in a play diem for a few months and then
they wanted me back and I said I'm only
coming if you fly me on Concorde and I
actually threw my uncle and I was just
like thinking oh my god you bunch of
wankers
it's like Derrick but it was kind of
just you know what it was kind of just
that's what it was like in those days
Joe
suddenly we didn't have a superstar -
you chose before that to go on I mean it
was kind of just hey hey oh it's all
about being in the right place at the
right time with the biggest mouth well
you were positioned based on the brand
the London had you were given an unfair
advantage there right you had
competitive advantage because you were
only the British DJ that's come over and
you know taken you don't have there's no
fact-checking
right come on it's a SoundCloud and say
actually [ __ ] and of course not they
didn't give a [ __ ] cuz you know all it
wanted all they wanted was the word
London and they wanted the day at the
wag club or any of the other venues
night later so kind of that's how it was
you know they're what you you you had
nothing to fall back on apart from you
like your last set she go in vain and
and I kind of yeah it's mad so well then
what we playing I playing early house
yeah house it kind of started off with
things like Luther Vandross and you know
chuck akan and all that stuff and that
was out at that time and then kind of
progressed slowly into we play old disco
and then from old disco winning into
early house the only child rate stuff
what what your are we talking here I
should know this stuff I'm ready but
we're talking I said I was 18 so I'm 55
now this year so work it out yourself
55 to 20 certainly okay so you're
talking like late eighties early
nineties i guess so i mean you you know
for the people listening that house
heads you know that love defected and
and good like quality modern I guess
modern house brands um that is seen as
one of the glory periods right for this
putting element of house no totally was
you know I used to go to Sam that used
to go to Paradise Garage I was you know
a regular L at garage and you know I had
an amazing time you know and it's like I
was first one me immensity swindles with
the first
never to bring frankly not to London to
get him to play so we groped him over
and he played with us at this Gunkel
jungle which we did on a Monday yes the
kind of thing you know there was none of
that whole my god we got this person
we've got that person at that point in
time that come a few years later when
everything suddenly got a lot bigger to
go well I mean at that point we had
Larry Levan who was classed as the
superstar teacher because he played at
Paradise Garage you know but it kind of
Rose you've got to meet these people you
realize that they weren't superstars
languages people having fun taking a lot
of drugs and having a really good time I
mean like myself yeah you know unlike
though most of those people I didn't
know when to stop
okay so we've got we've touched on one
of the defining characteristics I
suppose of your early DJing career yeah
what can you remember your first drug uh
my first drug
yeah my first thing I ever took was
cocaine poppers I did Papa used to do
poppers before that you know amyl
nitrate yeah I kind of I moved I didn't
even smoke at that point I I didn't
smoke until I was 21 and then I remember
the first time I ever took cocaine I
hated it I actually hated the ceiling it
made me feel repair annoyed and what I'm
never doing that again and then I one
night I was outside heaviness which is
in the movie I tell you in the film I
and I I met with a gang of guys going
into heaven and one of them happened to
be Freddie Mercury and hung out with
that lot and then we went back to their
house in Holland Park and and that's um
not for me cocaine friendly offered me a
line of cocaine I was like I don't do it
I joined my I care and of course did it
straight away
and uh that was kind of it that was my
drug of choice and you know it then it I
didn't do it for a little while I
remember I didn't do it for about I
think about six seven months I didn't go
near it again and then it was a real
major heroin
v thing going on in London majority of
people in London and that's on the club
scene we're really good big smack heads
and so I kind of anti that anyway
because all my friends were taking that
so you know
it was inevitable that I was gonna end
up being a junkie this is my blood
yeah I get it I get it so cocaine
obviously is a good drug for people that
are partying a lot and how often were
you going out was it seven nights a week
what was like partying just one one gang
sort of mesh well I mean you know I kind
of suddenly I had no goals I wasn't one
of these people who felt right okay in a
year's time I want to be this and then I
want to go on to professor I never I
never had that I was always you know
like I always been in the moment and I
kind of just you know I just I'd arrived
typing was my life clubbing was
everything suddenly you know I'd gone
from being this inverted you know kind
of shy hiding behind my fat hiding
behind things to actually being
discovering who I was and you know so
clubbing was it was it was it become my
life had become a job it become
everything you know so I was out seven
nights a week and you know slowly but
surely those out those seven nights
table it would be three or four nights
I'd do drugs and there would be five or
six nights on active tracks you know it
was never ever a problem the first I
didn't I never had a drop for the first
twelve years it wasn't a problem so
until 28 sort of age yeah 27 a problem
like I remember get I remember my 27th
birthday and members saying to my mom I
don't want to leave beyond 27 and my mom
was like why I was just like I had no I
just thought sit 27 was like kind of the
end of the road type thing my mom's like
don't be so stupid
27 your life and I was just like no no
and of course when I got to 28 I was
guided some of the reason I was gay that
I didn't I when I was 27 I thought you
know I gave it a good [ __ ] shot me
show you and I kind of just and that
kind of when it all kind of she's like
the drug taking the drug used to become
abuse it went from used to abuse and I
was in started abusing drugs I started
you know I'd be up for four or five
nights on the trot you know so talking
about the the years before drug use
became abuse yeah
was a typical week like took talked me
through today so I would go out Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday night
you know I would literally at that point
in time I was still living in Battersea
which was where my mom and dad lived
which is just over the river which is
central London so it was mean I had
everything took 10 minutes 20 minutes in
skating solo from my house so I so I
kind of just I would be out and because
I was living at home I didn't ever
everyone eats go home I build his
illegal drinking clubs in Soho so you
would go through these illegal drinking
clubs like 79 one was called and we had
a top called The Pink Panther which was
a gay 24-hour illegal drinking Club and
you'd go about 3:00 in the morning and
by 6:00 a.m. it would've been raided by
the police and you'd go out you walk
around the block and you'd go back in
and kind of that was just that added to
it everything was just like you know the
thrill of the police raiding something
and you know so that would be like
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday so
you're not DJing through the week I was
running my own night on shoes about the
wag Club at that point in time and then
I was running Saturday nights on white
Club as well I had to time the white
Club was like third place to go I mean
there would be a key around like a three
hour waiting to get in fact on a
Saturday night and we we basically want
the door up I'll not stay no you can't
come in you can come in we just get
whatever we want door refunds no sorry
you can't come in Europe you're not
totally and I'm taking care it was a
freak you know so that was Saturday's
and then wobbles a new club opened
called the limelight which was opened in
a big church and in the eighties it was
like the place late 80s early 90s the
place to go and they basically brought
me in you know yet again I met with the
owner called a local paycation and they
had these clubs all over they'd one in
New York which was the place to go
they'd this and they one in Atlanta and
they were only trove nice one in London
it was only show us be having in the
tissues Church
and I remember having a meeting them
saying you need to happen you need to
don't employ me
and they were like why I said because if
you don't I'll just annihilate your club
and say the [ __ ] that would come out
of my mouth and these guys are like yeah
yeah so they employed me and like a
month of working for them before I even
opened I've become like the musical
director of the limelight and I was like
on a retainer of ridiculous amounts of
money and it was at that point you know
I had suddenly had all this money I'd
took like I had my own office you know I
just turned 18 you know I was kind of
like just running so many different
things and and little with projects and
scams going on in London and you know it
kind of just I got swept away with it I
got swept away with it you know I had I
felt that I had to be there every night
I had to take the more drugs than
everybody else and it kind of just you
know that kind of just become who I was
it was [ __ ] speaking as someone who
started club promotion in 2006 which is
early by today's standards but late by
yours and me and my business partners
started running events and I've got a
very similar story without the the
hectic drug use and the and the
celebrities and Boy George and stuff
like that unless you can't you already
sure and no you don't know you don't
okay but I understand and I can speak
from personal experience about what it's
like to be a young guy who finds himself
having never been in a position of
authority or being renowned potentially
not being liked by people or or having
people need you and in that sense very
quickly can become your identity and you
can wrap yourself around it and what I
found it slightly different to yours me
my business partner started associating
or at least me not not Darren he's a lot
more it was a lot more stable of me he's
got two completely unsafe we've got two
easier two kids and two dogs it's
impossible for
pasture yeah our Fisher what I did was I
started associating my sense of
self-worth and well-being with the
success of the business a cushy do it
seems like with you perhaps it was to do
with of the partying to do with a
cleanse of renown it become more about
ego and the ego got so big because you
know people were blowing smoke up my
house I couldn't do no wrong was having
two nights a week two running two nights
a week at the limelight with my name on
my name was everywhere suddenly gone
from being this fat obnoxious kid to
being in the Sunday papers you know
suddenly in supplements I was suddenly
doing in abusive things and it just like
kind of got bigger and bigger and bigger
and I kind of you know in those days
fashion lunches come into play again I
was like we had to show and John Paul
Gautier you know I was wearing everybody
wanted me to wear their clothes it was
insane
and you know of course you know you get
you give something those that stuffed as
an 18 year old I don't know what to do
with it it's gonna drop on exactly and
like you know it's like [ __ ] pig in
[ __ ] you know seriously no I had no
tools to deal with that general I mean I
kind of just you know I the only way I
could deal with it was by taking loads
of drugs and and riding it what did the
dirt how did the drugs help well the
kind of drugs kind of led me into this
like full sense of okay they fed the ego
they fed the ego they kind of took away
the fear you know I are you know the
fear being found out I've always
suffered from imposter syndrome you know
and I always had that fear of oh my god
I'm gonna get seen found out here you
know uh and kind of you know the the
enjoyment of what I actually started off
by doing by DJing you know I kind of
always thought when I look back on I
always think because it was never a
Chosen job and it was never a chosen
path I think that's why I kind of tried
to destroy it so much she go well I mean
it's kind of was like it wasn't
something I studied to do I didn't set
out to be that and she kind of is like
okay this is why I'm falling into I
think George yeah George says
quite nicely in the film that when
everybody else was on brand-building
I was uh partying everyone else was
building a name for themselves I was off
just building boys
charmagne and because I always had that
fear of of III always had a fear of
success is really weird the bigger I got
the more destructive Michael so and I've
always been like that I'm still like it
today but today I kind of have a cap to
my I work a program around it you know
so there be area as well as something my
career is going like this and then I'll
be over here pouring parents in on
something just drawn to create a smoke
screen so that you can't really see who
I am because it's you know it's a it's a
it's a it's a weird one and you know at
that point in time I got success was
given to me on such a good a a massive
scale I mean you know I was doing TV
stuff I had a show a kiss I was all
there it was all there yeah and you know
and of course my mouth the way I was
destroyed that Gigot anything I wouldn't
Janet Street poor at that point was like
had a BBC TV for youth and she gave me
like this job she'd lined up all this
presenting stuff for me and she has a
part of the build up to I'd have to go
and outside concerts and voxpop where
you stand outside closes - hey what why
have you come to see so-and-so and all
that rubbish and I couldn't speak I'd be
so coked of mine ah I couldn't speakers
should come and take the mic off me and
then like just send me home and you know
there was so many of those golden
opportunities that I always thought
doesn't matter I'll get it again
do you know what I mean it's kind of the
ego had taken over
I suppose it's kind of see what what the
drugs do is they stop you from being
able to ask or do that introspection
they don't allow you to ask those
questions because they create a buffer
between what you see inside and how you
feel and it means you know you don't
ever have to worry about well hang on
maybe I should feel anxious upset
regretful whatever about Janet's report
are just saying I blew it again or this
not happening or that not happening or
whatever and obviously you know drugs
are a pretty sure fire way to stop you
from ever having to feel feelings
I totally changes the way I felt like
all drugs you know I would take drugs to
change the way I felt because I was
never happy with in the who I was you
know I never got to that point I just
think you know what your [ __ ] stinks
she does I never ever got that feeling I
always had to counteract the way I was
feeling by taking those drugs or
drinking on it
because I always thought less than I
never felt that I deserved the success
that I had because it wasn't my chosen
success I never thought that I deserved
to be where I was because it wasn't
something goes set out to do something
like that on you go what I mean so
therefore it was I kind of like cuckoo
to everybody else's nests you know and
it was kind of weird you know with that
drug of choice that cocaine it's kind of
like the famous line that Markham once
said was the cocaine will get get you
ready for the party but it won't take
you to the body you know so you'll spend
16 hours getting ready at home and you
won't leave the flat it's true you know
I thought it was like for me yeah was
there never a concern with money they
don't know you getting paid a lot but it
sounds like you were sniffing even more
never I uh you know I'd got myself to
this position where I was getting paid
you know you gotta remember at that
point in time we will become superstars
after that the Oakland folds my whole
circle of friends if you go back and all
those there was Danny Rampling
was MIPS of Paul Oakenfold sack sure all
those of these DJ's suddenly became the
biggest superstars and we would I would
be traveling up the boat way down the
motorway playing all over the place
poor bastard nuts and money you know and
of course I was on this massive
retaining from the limelight and they're
like stop that so it always went upwards
to go alameen and then suddenly you know
I was getting record deals I bought a
house in in better London which was
incredible it's called the Cooper
cottage on Queens Square very apt and uh
you know I had suddenly I had this
wealth you know I had so much money I
had so much money and you could
essentially weren't sniffing enough to
make a dent in that uh I was sniffing
enough to make considerable dent
they always get coming so whatever I
spent I knew I was getting again I was
always like no I remember up that house
I talked to when I left that house I got
I got thrown out of that lost that house
and the day that I left it I left one
mirror and which was the mirror I used
cuts chop lines on mirror let everything
else there just be the TV everything and
everyone was like well why you're not
taking stuff because it's fine I get it
again Chiyo LaLanne and this kind of
there's always that throwaway lifestyle
that kind of just brought me to my knees
in the end yeah very very blase again it
it's weird right because only with the
benefit of hindsight do we look at that
version of Tony with sympathy right
because at the time it must have been
this guy's got it all sorted like he's
got so much he's getting free drugs he's
basically getting paid for being a
[ __ ] like he's getting you know and
it's only it's what I think we need to
see or people need to try and look with
a little bit more nuance a young success
in a good DJ's like Avicii I'm friends
with tons and tons of DJ's third less
Avicii you know vici yeah oh another one
you know I remain just couldn't cope
with success couldn't cope with the
idiots because what happens is when we
get to that that that place we're not on
our own we've got 30 other tickets with
us and those other 30 tickets are
telling you what you want to hear that
they're filling you up you know what
what happens is that you had suddenly
realized that you're the body and and
when you when you get to that place
where you think you're the party
everybody else thinks you're the party
so you know they fuel what your beliefs
are and because you're away and means
for them to get more and you know the
realization is today that you get clean
this is the day that you realize you're
not the body
to go out of a man and you know with
people like a beach here they don't
stand a chance
they didn't attention she come on I mean
it was there and it's you know it's
difficult it's hard to say to people you
should feel sorry for this young
superstar who's
worth all this money who's got all these
records but is most people around him so
what they didn't want to around him but
you know the the the the yes people that
pulling the strings that behind them at
supplying me with drugs and the day that
I remember speaking to him he wanted to
get clean and you know he started coming
to meetings with us and stuff like that
and you know the powers that be behind
that didn't want that people don't want
that because they can't control you they
can no longer until you know it's a meal
bitten all over all over a gap you know
everybody pretends that they don't want
you to be in that position but they
can't they you're in that position
because they can control you in that
position
shego what I mean I would stop traveling
I wouldn't fly anywhere like and unless
I knew there was gonna be what I wanted
at the other end
I remember one trip I had to go to Hong
Kong and it was a big money truck job
and I was like I'm not going and I
remember getting to the airport and my
managers like you got you on the plane
knows I'm not [ __ ] going nowhere yeah
I mean I've been up for three nights I
mean I spank as well and it was like is
that you've got to get on that plane I
was like I'm not going I literally made
a phone call a fake [ __ ] phone call
to this guy you've got this guy say yeah
I'll meet your plane I've got you know
got an AIDS for you and I was talking to
this guy and I was like okay great
we got on the plane the guy didn't even
exist it was somebody one of his mates
so I go end up in Hong Kong and I was
there for four days five days and I
couldn't get any I couldn't get my drug
of choice and all I could get was ease I
remember doing a [ __ ] rocket fuel and
I ended up I set fire to the hotel room
Samael yeah I woke up on smoking in
motel rooms set by to the bed and I woke
up in hospital covered in iodine bright
orange iodine that covered me from its
toll I was like where am I and yeah I
tried to blame it on the light bulbs I
know must have been the light bulbs run
the mirror I was like [ __ ] smoking in
bed but I literally so out for my not on
ease and after that I was kind of what
I'm not doing
again geo I mean I'm not flying anywhere
I would get to the airport and just
decide now I'm going back to the
dealer's house so I've become a loose
cannon so people just stop booking me
stop flying me out to places which for
somebody at me like me at that point in
time it was great because I just won't
go anywhere
good cuz I still earn that money here
and you man you wanted the familiar
mentalness of home not though Cornelia
man on that's all rod you know I had a
triangle towards the end which I always
exchange people when I meet though you
know I had it there was a triangle of
addiction it was no ah I would leave my
house I would go to the dealers I would
stare the dealers that link the dealers
go to work go back to my house for two
days then go back that was the triangle
and then it was always so alcohol
cocaine
[ __ ] [ __ ] alcohol cocaine that was it
that was that the thing I could never do
one about one without the other two it
was the same way the same as my pattern
no traveling or going out of my comfort
zone and what towards the end it had to
be set in stone I need to know where I
was going on I need just know that I was
gonna get what I wanted it interesting
that you're out of control
in some regards well completely over the
overly controlling of your own life in
other regards you know I always say is
my [ __ ] you know they should smell like
the [ __ ] but it was my [ __ ]
it was like you know I I you know I
could control the little that I had to
control and that's all I needed to
control anything beyond that going to
the airport checking in get on a plane
[ __ ] that why I don't need to do that to
go and then I just saw that or that
house can go or this can go that can go
and that was that was always a much
easier option you know and I think
towards the end of my using I was only
happy when I had no money because I knew
I wasn't I couldn't use you know I'd be
a Wednesday and I couldn't even afford a
packet cigarettes by new Thursday I'd be
working again to your domain so that
Black Wednesday I would add there would
be some ease in this disease
that enabled me to sleep alright and
just really say I don't need sleep as
today so you you said that your drug of
choice was cocaine wasn't it yeah pretty
much predominantly what it was oh no no
no that was a drug of choice you know
the drug of any other drugs I got man
John you know I used to marzipan
diazepam rohypnol they was kind of like
the pegging parts of the cocaine so I
would take okay I take Downers to
suppress the cocaine I would drink
alcohol to level cocaine on our table
and then of course I discovered three
Basie and crack and then I discovered
crystal meth and you know it's just the
natural progression it was a natural
progression you know suddenly there'd be
a new drug and said well you need to try
this lovely like long oh I don't like
and then BOOM Bob drunk on a map for two
years she go all domain it was kind of
less like anything that could take me
somewhere else but then being in here
and being in was the only thing that was
too much for you anything that was too
strong or that you said you didn't want
to do crystal meth the first time I do
crystal meth I just thought I'm never
ever touching that again the comedown
was so bad I remember staying on chill
on box will bridge wanted to throw
myself in because I live right by it at
that point and and I was like sits
sitting there and it was raining and my
memory could can't do this anymore I
can't do this in mode you know and then
I thought oh [ __ ] that lis cigarettes
and went over so I went home to get my
cigarettes look good once it got home
the sad cigarette I'm looking at back
out again but you know it was that if
you had been two more minutes on that
bridge nobody would have jumped in you
know because the content was so severe
and I thought you know what I'm never
doing that again
and and it wasn't the never doing the
drug again I was never going to come
down again from it so I had every
intention of still smoking it I just
thought if I leveled it and worked it
out so that I didn't have to come down
like I didn't do with cocaine know
people just gold you must have have you
come down never had to come down I was
always on it she gonna mean you know as
I say to people when I you you know I
used an abused drugs for 28 years and
there was never a point where I wasn't
on trial
for 28 years I was on something which I
even when I slept you know and I I and
you know I knew that the last five years
I would sleep in when I finally
Wednesday I would sleep in the recovery
position because I was that scared that
I was gonna choke on my own vomit every
night is so bizarre so so that's getting
us towards 27 now 27 28 I'm gonna guess
yeah yeah and then that's when you said
it really started to turn into like a
spiral out of control
well did the crystal meth didn't come to
a lot later so the crystal meth was at
the end of my talk to you about 27 28
that kind of was like you know we've
gone through ecstasy
we've gone back onto cocaine I'd moved
to New York I moved back from New York I
lived in New York for a year thinking
that okay you know because ecstasy was
really good at that point in time in New
York so I thought I was gonna stay there
and just a traveling around the world on
an international drug store totally 100%
because I could earn the money that I
was getting and I couldn't command that
money for those audiences um so yeah I
kind of like it kind of just gone from
partying the party just didn't stop it
kind of went from party to three-day
binge is four day binges and then the
psychosis started and kind of like light
started to lose the plot little I kind
of would read it back in and just think
I can't do this I would end up in really
dark situations and end up in places
that no human being should ever end up
and I kind of just thought used to think
like a real problem this is a problem so
what I would do is we just change dealer
or I would change the situation I would
change the scenario I would change
circles of friends couple things II it's
a proxy for making progress isn't it
it's it's an analogy an analogous
situation that works side by side with
what could be moving forward but it's
not it's just it it's just different
yes I used to call it who bring out the
hula because you know it's like it's
like you know you stick you stick the
nozzle of the Hoover into the Hoover bag
and all of its going where is the same
old [ __ ] been regurgitated
constantly but you feel that you're
doing something about it I'm actually
cleaning people people do that in all
sorts of all sorts of ways right you
know perfect example let's go to another
area that I touch on a lot which is
productivity a lot of people will talk
about how they they've got this new
nootropic or I've really worked out my
my morning caffeine timing and I'm like
dude you work with your phone on your
desk next to your laptop like you're
sweating the small stuff and to talk
about psychosis and micro dosing yeah
you've got Twitter open that is not
where you're doing your work um I got a
little story for you about Christoph
'support eric prydz at the moment he's
okay DJ from the north of nothing I've
known him for ten years phenomenal guy
and I had him on the podcast and he um
he was telling us about a story about
when he was at the back end of his world
tour and he'd been onto our thing for
roundabout six weeks and he went to bed
in a hotel on the Thursday night South
America somewhere yeah and he remembers
looking at his calendar and thinking the
next time that I get a bed proper bed is
like Tuesday it's Thursday and he's got
a gig goes straight from the gig to the
airport get on the plane to get a couple
of hours sleep do all this sort of stuff
so that finishes up at the end of a long
tour where he's kind of a real intense
and he doesn't have a tour manager
either which is an interesting one for
him so he plays his big show has his big
high has all this energy goes back to
the hotel it's him and room service on
his own in a dark room right so he's got
this incredible crescendos of up and
down and then he gets back to Newcastle
gets into his house and essentially
after that enters a state of psychosis
that's from everything that's happened
over the last six weeks anyway it's a
morning time about 5:00 in the morning
6:00 in the morning and he comes to he
describes this situation he'd been
watching like QVC late-night TV that's
the only thing that's on at 5:00 in the
morning and he'd realized that his hair
was [ __ ] so he went to Asda and he comes
to to find himself sat on the floor of
the toiletries aisle in Asda and he's
got one of
every hair product out on the floor and
he's just taken a little bit and
slapping it on his head and taking a
little bit of this wax and slapping it
on his head and taking a bit in his Jail
and slapping it on his head and he comes
to and he's like what am i what am i
what am i doing here
ah not too sure stands up gets a floret
of broccoli 48 dishwasher tablets and
just walks out and it was it he was like
and at that moment I thought you know I
probably could do is speaking to
somebody you [ __ ] a hell and that's
just from sleep dead
yeah I mean I used to stay up for four
or five days and I would be out and I
live those ones one one time I was in
Liverpool Street Station train station
and I was of all my friends I was like
talking to people and and then they were
morphing into the wall and I was like
and I was like running after people
getting old you see my mate and I was on
my own I don't know how I got there
I lived I lived like in Brick Lane at
that point salut Street Station
obviously I traveled there to go home
but I was like talking to people and
then cars would pull up and I was trying
to get in cars and the cars weren't
really there it was insane and it went
on and on like managed to get home a
moment being in my flat my boyfriend
saying to me Tony you do realize these
people aren't here and I'm like what you
want to power I'm in the bed I was in
the liberal and having a party with like
eight or eight and I'm my friends all
dancing an unlit jamming device they
weren't there and I remember eating soup
on the bed and like he was like what
you're doing I was like I'm eating and
he's like Tony you realize this isn't
real and he called an ambulance and the
ambulance come and they were gonna
section me and they took me to a store
and they did all he said in the luckily
it's cuz I hadn't slept I've gone into
this state my brain had completely gone
but I could it was at that moment two
days afterwards I realized why how
people get committed and how they get
section where their minds go my mind had
gone I'd lost my mind and people were
like I was talking to me when they were
like mall thing literally morphing into
car seats [ __ ] mental and that was
just from that's from being awake all
that time and taking so much cocaine
that my brain couldn't go my brain
started and that was kind of at those
turning points of where life is suddenly
got a lot lot lot lot darker because you
know I was losing I was losing the block
even the most balanced among us I think
are only five days of no sleep away from
being sentimental from being that hobo
on the street that shout that shout
words and has poo on the back of his
shoe laundry I sent all of us our and
the the thin line of sanity that all of
us are kind of wobbling on right you're
only a couple of travesties in your life
away from something sending you down a
spiral and the the good work the problem
that I feel so much like sympathy for
that particular area of your career
because had you have had a little breaks
had it have been like five years on one
year off five years on one year off
during that one year you could have done
some work built up some resilience you
know it started to do the introspection
that you required to be a baker no way
but Chris if I'd had a year off and went
back to into what I was doing older
tired why because my body would my body
wouldn't be enough to take the was what
I was doing again do you I mean it's
like literally you know my body had got
so accustomed to I was putting in it
they kind of built up resilience you
know my liver my kidneys and everything
you know kind of become dependent on
what I was doing when you stop doing
that stuff and you take time out and you
know addiction isn't something that you
can switch off and switch on in that
sense so when I both you know say I got
clean and I have a relapse that relapse
won't suddenly go back to one glass of
wine and one line it will go straight
back to six grams of coke and smoking
crystal meth all night where I left off
my body won't get to take that so my
body will go into shock and shut down
and what happens is you can start to
shut down and the Mike's brain goes this
happens this will kill so many people
let's look at Amy Winehouse you know her
body couldn't take it she started
drinking again and that's what happens
you know people really underestimate the
power of what the alcohol and other
drugs did to the body she go on a main
and kind of so taking time out was never
an option anyway surprisingly
surprisingly actually was one of the
best safest things that you could have
done was not taking
Raik 100% that's interesting you know
and I used to call it chemicals Capaldi
because people still [ __ ] still ups
in awake still alive
it's like chemical scaffolding you've
got these structures right that are not
- but you're Alondra totally get that
so before we move on to kind of recovery
and the rest of this stuff I wanted to
ask what was one of the heaviest parties
that you can remember going to might be
the heaviest or just one that comes to
mind I kind of be every weekend when we
did trade I used to be resident a club
called trade which was a turn Mills is a
legendary club and trade was like the
first places in the country that opened
at 3 a.m. and went on to midday and it
was you you probably would have been got
that listen Burcham had nothing contrite
trust me
trade was like the mecca you had like an
alley called muscle alley what the
muscle mare is hung out yeah heavy
techno room we told you to there and all
those guys we did trade like they had
archways where you was queue up to buy
your drugs like proper dealer shops it
was insane and trade was like you know
it was groundbreaking its revolutionary
it was like third place to go so every
weekend kind of would be too heavy a
spike were you playing there I just
thought yeah my own room cool trade
light and I would you know that's kind
of where the disco Jesus fing games
wrong cuz we turn to seven records into
a 12-hour set I mean I'm just like that
was insane you know so I mean there was
so many and I would leave there and go
on all day sunday all night Sunday Jos
TPM and there all day Monday Tuesday
Wednesday so every weekend was kind of
like that and then I would then after
that there are other clubs that we
started called orange and fire in London
we started all those venues they will
come from my my desire to take drugs you
know and my friends desire to take drugs
we couldn't stop we so we would create
these after our parties speaking as
someone who's been in the industry for a
long time and a lot of the people that
are in it as well listening might get
this
there's a lot of the things that you're
talking about here that we now in the
industry nowadays are trying to recreate
but it didn't like it's the kiddies
version it's an earth diversion right so
you were talking about um the party the
the late night drinking club that's open
24 hours and then the police come and
they shut it down and then everyone kind
of runs around the corner and then they
come back like there is secret parties
that get done now but it's all that
happens is you get issued it via text
message at 7:00 p.m. on the night and
it's this raid culture that's made coach
we did that in the acid ounce days for
you to go to a phone box and have to
call a number and they tell you well
what fuel to go to okay you've got go 40
miles from here right when you get there
go to another phone box and it was like
you know it's like being in Scooby
[ __ ] dude it was like trying to get
to that phone box to find a field and
then you get there you're being a field
for two hours the police would come and
raid it 40,000 people would be sent home
and that's the kind of ways that's rape
culture you know people long for that
today yeah people long for the thrill of
that don't you think you look at this
now and it you know Lazo you have these
sort of pipes but it's the tickets
[ __ ] sold through fat so more a
ticket we're by [ __ ] ticket arena
right it's not it's not underground it's
dry it's people trying to recreate the
whole sense of the of the golden era
right and it is it's kind of I know that
it's tragedy and it I mean you know all
those people that are trying to create
that to name four of the tracks from
that time that they're trying to and the
artist name and I'm guarantee you they
don't know them you know and they they
they read about rave culture they dream
about rave culture you know there's
something really amazing you know and
the one will this lockdown and the way
we are we all put in our house is
something really creative and magical is
gonna come from this I really create my
magical because you know it's times like
this that some stuff starts to grow out
juices flow in our brains and we've got
a really good idea let's do this and you
know stop some really amazing stuff's
gonna come from this
I saw Jackie morn who's one of my good
buddies just been up with Roger Sanchez
and a be thick juice in their [ __ ]
they're producing tracks at 130 bpm
but you know in six months twelve months
time there is gonna be some ridiculous
EPS there's gonna be some amazing
berries you know there's gonna be you
know that all of that stuff's coming you
know what's pissing me off the most
about this is when I keep hearing these
idiots you know not Stu going in saying
any names but the Sun DJ say say you had
petitions a we should have a seven day
party and it's like [ __ ] off man do you
understand that night clubs and pubs are
gonna be like the lowest of the lowest
right down there on the videos after
cafes after restaurants it's all got
schools and colleges can't defend
factories are gonna come so it's gonna
be a slow turner we ain't gonna see a
nightclub open this year no way will we
see open a nightclub of ministers down
or any of those big club they're not
gonna open - October November December
no wait this is not gonna go away it's
like Italy and all these places then no
clubs gonna open it early until there's
a vaccine they've already said it you
know why would they go down get get it
under wraps and it's okay you can go out
partying again I know you go go back to
the gym start spreading this again it's
not gonna happen
use your head there isn't going to be no
big Vijay celebrations there's not
what's gonna happen is other avenues are
gonna come out of it and it's not gonna
be live streaming from your bedroom but
it's gonna be upper avenues did you
thank you did you see the defective life
defected live yesterday no get out
that is a shit-hot way to do it I know
everyone's new livestreams lot of DJ's
are you know but I mean I did one give
weeks The Evening Standard I did one
last week Barbie Nichols and live from a
garden and this Friday I'm doing a
massive one which is gonna get released
tomorrow I'm doing Victoria Beckham's
birthday party for the NHS lively live
versions you are a virtual birthday
party yeah it's her birthday she won't
soon buy all the key workers in the NHS
her birthday party bio my garden so I've
detailed the to our set reign all their
favourite tracks
live from our garden for the NHS and
people can donate and they can also
download the next day they can download
the playlist and they can also download
the set and all the money goes to the
NHS and key workers so that's this
Friday and that's gonna go out just from
her Instagram feed alone 228 million
then from David please I think he's got
something like a hundred yes so it's
gonna go out it's gonna go out by 2020
because they're all calling into our
tracks so the whole thing is just gonna
level up level up so we've been working
on it for weeks so tickets they're gonna
release it tomorrow which is Tuesday the
abbot of the the evidence they're gonna
really like that the press release is to
coming out tomorrow so I'm really
excited about that
I can't expect the men I'm doing one for
British phones and that's it I'm kind of
just like you know this is my job this
is my career I'm not there to DJ do you
I mean right now everyone's a bedroom
well you're a garden DJ I am a garden
it's fine that's my career I'm not I'm
not
DJing 42 people on a live feed that most
people do this is Taylor Taylor so for
the people that are just listening there
is a very very nice dog oh that's just
been brought in in the middle of the
screen I'm not I'm sorry sir I you don't
understand my love for dogs and now I'm
not gonna be able to focus on anything
except Taylor is a famous 14
she's the savior of all life she's the
best thing in the world amazing spirit
and she tries to be tailored trailer has
this magic about she's amazing
well I'm looking forward to seeing it
during the live stream and the best
thing I've seen avid listeners will know
I'm about to connect best thing I've
seen so far in lockdown is my friend
David Coverdale who was supposed to be
going away on a stag due to Istanbul and
his missus organised a virtual stag do
well he had all of his friends on skype
video yeah and he got dressed up he had
the inflatable hat and they were
drinking and they did the full night
there was a virtual stager and I was
like that's [ __ ] sick before we go
that's it but that's Equus it's all
about creativity and it's about you know
what we make the best with what we got
and it's about I think what people will
keep forgetting in this whole lockdown
like I can't I can't
I'm these I've lost fifty quid from not
doing that job look at what you have got
instead of what you haven't got and you
know what people are moaning about being
locked in doors you're not locked
indoors you're at home safe that's the
difference you go on I mean it's it's
not about being like oh I can't do this
I can't do that
just breathe this is this is a magical
time it's highlighted to me the people
that have a growth mindset and the
people that don't and the people that
have that growth mindset I'm seeing
flourishing in this situation and the
people that don't I'm seeing stagnating
and even regressing hundred percent 100
percent you know it's it's [ __ ] awful
time you know I lost one of my best
friends this morning my friend Debbie
she and her mum passed away on Sunday
last Sunday so her sister Jane who I
grew up with has lost not only a mum but
lost a sister in a week from this virus
and and then you got these idiots saying
oh you know it's not real it's not
happening and and the blah blah blah
she's like you know what the [ __ ] don't
get me started on David Icke in London
real yeah so many of them there's so
many of these [ __ ] and he's just
like you know what you tell that to the
key workers you tell that to the people
that not being able to say goodbye to
their own mums and sisters you know it's
heartbreaking
it really is it's just you know and you
know and people have the sad thing is
people are buying into it like what the
[ __ ]
so there's this thing called compensate
or control right yeah it's a
psychological effect in times of great
uncertainty people will turn to more
spurious or more narrative based
solutions so for instance someone that's
given an own uncertain medical diagnosis
is more likely to see patterns in
meaningless static on a TV and the
reason is that we would much sooner
believe that the virus is going around
because of the plan of some malign
scientists or the
transhumanist lizard people whatever it
might be rather than just chance
mutation and that leads us to want to
create these crazy conspiracies because
it gives us it gives us a semblance it
personifies the the viruses at the
behest of someone someone shows this to
happen not just its random chance you
know yeah I want to ask if you were to
go back you might not even be able to
remember this if you go back and go
across most of the the big bits of your
deejaying career and you needed to
absolutely take the roof off with a
track what are some of the tracks that
you would drop from from back then oh
when you ask someone what their favorite
tracks are and you know straightaway you
that person stops to think because I
think if I say this is gonna sound like
I'm cheesy if I say that you know
there's tracks throughout my career that
are that you know the right time in the
right place you will take any route you
know the older classes Robin s where
lovers you know as Limerick and all that
stuff that I grew up with that people
think is cheese now on major tracks you
know some day sees he Rogers in the
right place there's so many amazing
amazing electric tracks of a bit of
every era of every decade that I just
like go back to you know that's what so
I'm blessed so blessed so many of my
sets that I play these days it's
especially for fashion so it's so I'm
in-house DJ now for Versace
so when I do that stuff for Donatella
she wants all the old classics so I can
reel that stuff out I had the most
amazing time you know I couldn't I could
not pinpoint one track they chew that's
it because there's so many there's so
much so many to go I mean he's kind of
just like you know I'm my own person
favorites that I are that tracks that
make that means so much to me to go
animate and I wouldn't play out because
I get too emotional Wow yeah I am I
think Christoph cause II mentioned
earlier on I think he's got a couple of
those where he struggles he sometimes
struggles to drop them because he gets
too
and they involved also I've got I'm
gonna put it out there it's the biggest
drug music is the best and biggest drug
I've ever taken it has the ability to to
transport you to anywhere in the world
and to be with people that you're no
longer with and no longer with us you
close your eyes and you play that track
they're there and that's that's the
magic and music and you know when I'm DJ
and I and I'm very and I get one of
those sets where I can take people on a
journey it always ends in tears full way
no because I will play a track of legend
Joe like Frankie Knuckles tears I mean
come on you know who can't lose it to
something like that
Barry White ecstasy by Barry why it's
just like no take that those certain
tracks couldn't take me back to that mud
ridden filth I first heard them in you
know the sounds of blackness the
pressure will take me straight back to
some factories with Frankie Knuckles
when the first time you ever played it
you know there's so many things that
that I had so much euphoric recoil
around so many different tracks because
I lived those tracks it's not I just no
one needs to choose me to them I
discovered in it without with a lot of
other people at the right time and you
know that's the beauty of it it's
because it's more than the music right
when you hear a track and the people
that are listening will know the old
tracks I think this is why we have
particular nostalgia and why so I just
stop you do that then not old tracks
Chris you know I mean it doesn't get old
no my point is tracks that music doesn't
timeless the perfect track it's time
this is not something that you go oh
that's a really old track oh that's it
it's not all musics timeless let me
reframe tracks that have been with late
for us for a significant duration at
time tracks have been with you for years
because what you get well the first time
you hear a track you hear the music and
you hear the sounds and you get the
emotional effect but as you hear that
track more and more and you're
experiencing something while that track
is playing that track when it then gets
played is more than the music it's the
compounding of every experience and
every time that you have heard that
track cool so teenage crimes the axe
well Remo dove that was my first season
in Ibiza
2010 and it's got that really haunting
beautiful kind of vocal emoji I'm 32
yeah Clarion you just remember that
because that was a year 2010 was like
peak Swedish House Mafia you know it was
one big house big room house was kind of
all the ready yeah and that that track
man like someone can drop that track
someone contract Eric drop Eric Prydz
opus and I'll lose man get that big oil
that big sort of ten-minute thing
because they stored back here that
feeling and that emotions here it's not
here this is stupid thinking it's here
this is the part of our brain that wants
to be loved it wants us to be hard it
once is to have that feeling of euphoric
recalls when our first ecstasy we ever
took it wants all of that stuff and
that's where it's stored and those
memories are stored here and as soon as
you play that track and you go straight
back to that point do you go what I mean
it will you it doesn't get better than
that it doesn't get that's it is you
know and that's one of this one of the
reasons why we spend it like that we
spend our lifetimes chasing them you do
we do you know did you ever do did i do
i beefer of course I did I bet you
didn't know what I did I beefer in 89 90
91 92 every I used to play amnesia my
first friend zone did Sandra Sandra
Sandra and host Sandrine and Jose owned
it and this is before it had a roof how
I used to go over I suppose Alfredo um
we I first went to our first play
tonight be for an AE
in 85 at KU then which is now pretty
large for a guy called boozy Leo I spent
a whole summer out there yeah I I've
always played I'd be fun
I was there last year doing get box I'm
there this summer to England's ya know
for me the island has so many memories
you know there's there's some amazing
hidden films going around at the moment
there's one on YouTube where I'm
interviewing aunty Webber all in 1989 at
privilege at KU know it's at a museum
and me and Andy are talking and I went
over the whole summer with a film crew
and meet Annie Rampling and all that
look we're all living in the same we
step we all staying's and say Villa oh I
interviewed everyone we felt we filmed
the whole island and then the guy that
did the film I don't know what happened
to me just disappeared with with the
films and they've just started
resurfacing now there's one on YouTube
at the moment the antiwaiver one what
should people search if Tony ng web role
it comes up 1989 amnesia but you know
there's like there's about whole week's
worth of film footage stop floating
around I would love to get you know I
know lost not last year to you before
they were showing them at pikes
yeah yeah so I know you know I want to
find out who's got them somewhere okay
so I want to I want to talk about
recovery now you you're in your living
this life in deep kind of it sounds like
there's been some experiences that have
been in stark contrast to the fun that
may be sort of eight teams into twenties
into early 20s and then it starts to
become from you said use to abuse yes
there is there an inflection point with
this is it the meth on the bridge or is
it something else or is it with Roger or
compounding over time I just built and
built and built go and you know what
happens is with addiction
each strips away Lee chisels away
yourself were that your self sustain it
leaves you with nothing and can let me
lock rocking backwards and forwards in a
room wanting to kill myself you know I
lost everything I lost my teeth I like
90 pound crystal meth I like I went
insane and and what happened was at the
end there was a god given moment one
evening I was in the club called the
cross rocking backwards and forwards as
I did my partner at the time came in and
you know he never came to the club and
it was a Friday night and I'd already
been out for two nights and I just
thought I can't cope it always makes me
it makes me want to cry because you know
it was that God give a moment I changed
everything I was from that night I denim
decided I couldn't go on cuz you know I
didn't think about where I was gonna be
next week or what was coming in going on
holiday all right what about was my
funeral I thought about who's gonna be
at my funeral what songs are gonna be
played at my funeral
and that was all I had to look forward
to was dying and then suddenly our I
decided that I do want to die and I've
got help and I went away to treatment I
went away to rehab for six months and I
came forward to London there's no when
you're in treatment they say you can't
go back to DJing you can't go back to
that life you can't go back to that
boyfriend you know you know and I was
like one looking back to anything I'm
going forward to it and I kind of kept
that momentum going and I'm now thirteen
years four months clean ah I had not
think when I came into treatment when I
went to the end of my using I won per
trainers I'm one tooth left and stay of
everything stay at freedom I have an
amazing house I had you know I you know
I think gifts beyond my wildest dreams I
have freedom I can do whatever I want in
life
I can at the moment you know right now
you're on modern with some podcast which
is obviously exactly what you want to be
doing yeah but you know I can do if I
had the freedom to do what I want
because you know I'm not chained to
anything I've just realized based on
your timeline of recovery
you've had your dog you've had your dog
Taylor since before you were clean yeah
I have you
so Taylor would say Gil present being
out for four or five days and I got
Taylor as a present for Maya
then-partner and I remember gang and you
know I've never talked called Reggie
before that and we want you another dog
to take just keep him company
and we got Taylor and then I got clean
entirely got pregnant while I was in
rehab she got raped by the other dog and
I know so basically Taylor's been
through everything with me
you know she's that's one saying she she
has this spirituality about her that
just is incredible though she you know
she knows every emotion she knows every
single yeah she's not she's one of a
kind and yeah so she's that she's on the
joys of three Capra
see videos do you think it's possible to
do the DJing life as a young guy and do
it in a well-balanced way because I
don't how do you how do you do that
there's some DJ's I can't even maybe
think I'm a in an industry of excess I
get stuff for free djs djs get paid well
some of them do well I just think that
it's you it's you this is your chosen
job this is your career you look at it
as your career you don't look it as a
party if you look at this if you're in
this because you want to party then
don't bother you know you're gonna burn
yourself out it's gonna end in tears you
look at this as a career and you have a
passion through music and you have the
love for music and you you want people
to UM to understand your passion then do
it for the right reasons and you can do
it constructively it's not because
you're creative in forever moving
forward I'm not standing in one place or
being in the jam job with the lid
screwed on and going around and round
and round then you're not going anywhere
as long as you keep going somewhere you
can do this you can do this you know you
don't have to burn yourself out to do
this for the love of a job because if
you have you know the one thing that we
all have in common is love the music you
know and I kind of think if this is your
chosen career and you have your gifted
within that career of knowing how you
know some people play music and some
people make music right a DJ you know
isn't about playing musics about reading
a dance floor it's about knowing your
are for them no I see so many
celebrities coming on going sunny I'm a
DJ no you're not DJ you're pressing play
there's such total difference you know a
DJ knows how to warm up a room it knows
how to take you on a journey that's the
difference I mean if you you don't have
to as I said before you're not the party
but there to facilitate the party that's
the you know thank you if you stick to
those rules you can't you can do the
struggle without burning yourself up I
think a lot of now the prevalence of
increased competition amongst nightlife
venues and social media which is a space
this tool which needs to be used I think
there's a lot a lot of promoters that
might be listening who feel that they
are the party I've always made this this
analogy ever since I started you know
like 15 18 years ago that there's two
types of club promoters one of them are
people who realize that they can make
good money quickly from filling clubs
and they have a capacity to it and the
second type there are people who love to
party and they've realized [ __ ] you know
I can get paid to get pissed and don't
get paid to get pissed down at the party
too long because a looser pie that's it
that's the difference and and the ones
that want to make money quickly on
around live you know the ones with the
biggest egos they got a number there's
gonna be another thirteen thousand
double people the same size e gonna take
their place you know it's a it's a
nightclub don't forget that that's all
it is is a party do you I mean you know
either do it well [ __ ] off it's as
simple as that
man the problem is that people believe
that it is crazy transcendent experience
that all of this stuff's going on they
start to believe they're on high price
especially you've got these people
blowing smoke up your ass you've got
drugs and parties and girls and guys and
all the rest of the girls that's all
happening but you're right there is and
I've said this to every member of staff
that's ever worked for us there's like
there's the Chris speech right when they
get promoted they become one of our
junior managers and the Chris speech
says mate no matter how far in we get
how long you stay with us whether you
become full-time or whatever it is don't
forget that it's people getting drunk in
a room to music and that's exactly never
ever gonna be and you know what you're
the promoter of a party you don't want
making music the music's the most
important thing in there don't treat
your DJ's like they're a bunch of [ __ ]
to go and may no one's outdoing the
Joffrey us like [ __ ] yeah yeah do you
know the DJ tickets okay so final final
few things now um Jake you said that
you'd met Prince Michael Jackson and
jay-z and were totally unimpressed by
any of them that's [ __ ] thank you
Prince Prince is one of the most amazing
geniuses I've ever what desert you know
how could you not be impressed by three
that was my question how can you you
know
Josie you know I've met so many people
from my grill let's hang out daddy wall
these people are geniuses - no I mean
how can you not be impressed by these
people or what you do the Masters oh
there are you know princess and someone
that used to winning the studio got
someone else to make these tracks for
him you know heat that God produced
everything the ever touched played every
instrument did everything how can you
not be impressed by that no ha no slaves
your answer cause I'm impressed
good good man imagine all of these
people so what's next what happened the
next what's next
hi there's a book I'm writing a book I
have loads and loads and loads of
matters all of a sudden I'm starting a
new TV channel program I'm doing a
YouTube channel ah I'm doing a yeah
there's a lot of starts coming up but
you know what it's all creative and it's
really I'm not you know I've been asked
to do a lot of silly things which I said
no to too long in the tooth that rubbish
should I mean um but for me our most
important thing is happiness as long as
I'm happy doing what I'm doing then it
will work what is happiness do you know
what makes you happy I mean this is
being at home with my partner David and
being home Taylor and being in the
moment not chasing what I'm looking to
finish I just don't had it's it's no not
it's not it having this is knowing that
what I've got right now is enough -
you're insane and making do you know
it's not about making do this - what's
wrong thing to say you know it's it's
it's about making magic of what you have
and that's what it's about and you know
there's so many things that are coming
no big could go Statesville - over the
last three years your careers really
took off and it's like no it hasn't
it's like been the 13 years of sobriety
and and recovery that has enabled me to
become the person who I was and who I am
today is that a person and that comes
from happiness
yeah I think you know I'm gone back in
the studio um we've defected there's
loads of stuff coming up just you know
do some really amazing things that are
in the pipeline that's so cool
but so I felt blessed you know I'm
blessed and no it's not that luck Luck's
winning the lottery you know being
blessed I'm blessed and sent that I got
a second chance of Iceland you know I'm
not gonna throw that away and I think
that every moment that we have is
precious
especially today win and you lose
someone you lose people in your life you
just can't really wait things no because
I don't need a drink or a drug pian I'll
stop I can do that very easily myself
but you know I but you know what happens
is at this part of my brain this took
the the program that had to work with in
Narcotics Anonymous which is how I stay
clean and sometimes it takes a while to
kick in and when it kicks in it gives me
a boot up the answer I need something
your behaviors are off key or the way
you're treating people the way we're
treating yourself it's about self care
as long as I'm looking after this
everything else falls into place
yeah so after lockdown who knows man
that's a beautiful message what a lovely
lovely way to end it yes thank you
I'm really excited I think you know
there's a lot of DJs and people in
nightlife who need to hear this kind of
message you know I'm around you notice
you haven't gone to the extremes perhaps
that you did yeah I recommend that
people also there's a part of you that
you could change what would it be and I
was you see none of it because you know
there's my journey who I am that [ __ ] I
went through that [ __ ] I created all
that stuff I went before his kind of
brought me to this point in my life and
now I think it
I changed any of that then I would be
where I am today in senses I wouldn't
have found what it was I was looking for
all that time about under my eye really
bad you to something but you know what
it's connected sir it's
weird one it really is yeah
life has an odd way of dropping
serendipity on us a lot doesn't it
there's some poetic irony that just
keeps on looping around you know you
know when we we showed the film that
Selfridges we did six nights of previews
in the film them to each night where we
acted I'm talking you know it's like it
looks like you an alien the guys were
not saying it's not at us
the films not a story of P is the story
of redemption and I've kept thinking why
are they saying that I'm you know it was
really it really is a story of
redemption and senses you know they when
you see the trailers for it all you
don't they use like dramatic light like
I spent a million pound on on drugs
they're not both people is out how can
you boast about that taking out of
context but they've used those lines
just so it catches people are people's
eyes when you see the story
there's no boasting in here That's not
me boasting about spending that money
much lesser far from it I wouldn't rent
lling in it you know um it destroyed my
life you know
um but what the boasting about there is
no boasting in it where it takes you -
you know I'm just blessed to be alive
I'm very glad that you are really really
you are I think the world's a brighter
place because of it so people want to
find out more about you keep up to date
with what it is you got going on why
should they go to Jake that Tony on
Instagram ah Malik there's a link on it
to my youtube channel I'm on Instagram
24 hours a day but I don't hate that
much you know I'm kind of you know some
addictions to have the addiction um yeah
they are on my youtube channel
yeah those are the two places you can
always find me amazing will be linked in
the show notes below of course I
recommend that you go and check out
because there are some fantastic memes I
think I don't think there's anyone
putting out a higher velocity of memes
and you are an Instagram at the moment
know what I get so many messages every
day of people saying to me thank you
you're helping us get through this thank
you feel sense humor no it's kind of
like though the messages that I get from
certain people you know so many messages
every day I reply so every one of them
because someone's taking the time to
message me so they deserve to get an
answer and that people are really
shocked that you you reply but I reply
they're like oh my god you have to was
expecting school why wouldn't I well my
message David Beckham and he doesn't
reply I always say I would say to take
them you need to start this is a you
problem they're a championship why
aren't you putting up more memes David
why isn't your music track selection for
your misses his birthday better and why
aren't you replying EDM so that's what I
want to know look Tony it's been it's
been fantastic thank you so much for
coming on I'm gonna look forward to the
book coming out and to following a
YouTube channel it's been brilliant if
you've enjoyed the episode drop Tony a
message or you know what find me at
Criswell axe on all social media like
share if you new here hit the subscribe
button
but for now Tony man thank you good
bless
[Music]
you